Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
This day is the perfect day to simulate the
kinematics of yarn and cloth on our computers.
As you just saw, this is not the usual intro
that we use in every episode, so, what could
that be?
Well, this is a simulation specifically made
for us, using a technique from today’s paper.
And it has a super high stitching density,
which makes it all the better, by the end
of this video, you will know exactly what
that means and why that matters.
But first, for context I would like to show
you what researchers were able to do in 2012
and we will see together how far we have come
since.
This previous work was about creating these
highly detailed cloth geometries for digital
characters.
Here you see one of its coolest results where
it shows how the simulated forces pull the
entire piece of garment together.
We start out by dreaming up a piece of cloth
geometry, and this simulator gradually transforms
it into a real-world version of that by subjecting
it to real physical forces.
This is a step that we call yarn-level relaxation.
So, this paper was published in 2012, and
now, nearly 9 years have passed, so I wonder
how far have we come some since?
Well, we can still simulate knitted and woven
materials through similar programs that we
call direct yarn-level simulations.
Here’s one.
I think we can all agree that these are absolutely
beautiful, so what’s the catch?
The catch is that this is not free, there
is a price we have to pay for these results.
Look.
Whoa, these really take forever.
We are talking several hours, or for this
one, almost even an entire day to simulate
just one piece of garment.
And it gets worse, look, this one takes more
than two full days to compute.
Imagine how long we would have to wait for
complex scenes in a feature-length movie with
several characters.
Now, of course, this problem is very challenging,
and to solve it, we have to perform a direct
yarn-level simulation.
This means that every single strand of yarn
is treated as an elastic rod, and we have
to compute how they react to external forces,
bending deformations, and more.
That takes a great deal of computation.
So, our question today is, can we do this
in a more reasonable amount of time?
Well, the first Law Of Papers says that research
is a process.
Do not look at where we are, look at where
we will be two more papers down the line.
Let’s see if the law holds up here!
This new paper promises to retain many important
characteristics of the full simulation, but
takes much less time to compute.
That is amazing.
Things stretch, bend, and even curl up similarly,
but the simulation time is cut down a great
deal.
How much less?
Well, this one is five times faster, that’s
great.
This one, twenty times, oh my!
But it gets better!
Now, hold on to your papers, and look!
This one is almost 60 times faster than the
full yarn-level simulation.
My goodness!
However, of course, it’s not perfect, in
return, pulling effects on individual yarns
is neglected, so we lose the look of this
amazing holey geometry.
I’d love to get that back.
Now, these examples were using materials with
a relatively small stitching density.
Now, the previous, full yarn-level simulation
method scales with the number of yarn segments
we add to the garment.
So, what does all this mean?
This means that higher stitching density gives
us more yarn strands, and the more yarn strands
there are, the longer it takes to simulate
them.
In these cases, you can see the knitting patterns,
so there aren’t that many yarns, and even
with that, it still took multiple days to
compute a simulation with one piece of garment.
So, I hope you know what’s coming.
It can also simulate super high stitching
densities efficiently.
What does that mean?
It means that is can also simulate materials
like the satin example here.
This is not bad by any means, but similar
simulations can be done with much simpler
simulators, so our question is, why does this
matter?
Well, let’s look at the backside here, and
marvel at this beautiful scene showcasing
the second best curl of the day.
Loving it.
And now I hope you are wondering what the
best curl of the day is.
Yes, here goes, this is the one that was showcased
in our intro, which is Two Minute Papers curling
up.
You can only see the footage here.
Beautiful.
Huge congratulations and a big thank you to
Georg Sperl, the first author of this paper,
who simulated this Two Minute Papers scene
only for us, and with a super high stitching
density.
That is quite an honor.
Thank you so much!
As I promised, we now understand exactly why
the stitching density makes it all the better.
And if you have been watching this series
for a while, I am sure you have seen computer
graphics researchers destroy armadillos in
the most spectacular manner.
Make sure to leave a comment if this is the
case.
That is super fun, and I thought there must
be a version of that for cloth simulations.
And of course there is.
Now, please please meet the Yarnmadillo.
The naming game is very strong here.
And just one more thing.
Georg Sperl, the first author of this work
was a student of mine in 2014 at the Technical
University of Vienna where he finished a practical
project in light simulations programs, and,
he did excellent work there.
Of course he did.
And I will note that I was not part of this
project in any way, I am just super happy
to see him come so far since then, he is now
nearing the completion of his PhD, and this
cloth simulation paper of his was accepted
to the SIGGRAPH conference.
That is as good
as it gets - well done Georg!
Thanks
for watching and for your generous support,
and I'll see you next time!